school children are told that unlike
sticks and stones words will never hurt
them but a nine-year-old girl in germany
has been
punished by her teachers for speaking
her native turkish in the playground
her parents are now planning to sue the
school our correspondent peter oliver
has the story
there's a row brewing in southwest
germany over the languages
spoken in school it's after a
nine-year-old girl was given
this punishment essay to write for
speaking turkish
the children speak german in school in
germany the official language
is german you want us to speak german
the schools are german
if we speak turkish the children won't
understand us
we are not allowed to speak our mother
tongue so we can speak german that's all
i know
the local school authority told rt that
the
german-only policy is in place so that
everyone
students and teachers all speak a common
language
43 of children are from migrant
backgrounds
so it's important for everyone to speak
the same language so the school can
fulfill its educational mission
the rule we all speak german is also
part of the class rules at school
which drawn up jointly by all pupils and
explained at parents evenings
it was agreed that in the event of a
violation of this rule
an essay on the topic why we speak
german at school
must be written that's not good enough
for the family
or their lawyer who says that this rule
targets the turkish language
in particular if a student during the
[Music]
the school break is talking for example
fluent english
or fluent french or fluent chinese or
fluent latin
i cannot believe that the teacher would
say oh this is forbidden
and please don't do this i think every
teacher
would say and show this person as an
example for
good teaching and good knowledge the
family
want to know if there was an unequal
treatment
of that child you cannot
forbid to talk in your mother tongue
yeah and this of course affects all your
personality
all your identity and also is
protected by the human rights of the
german
constitutional law there was not such a
general rule
to talk only in german
language in this school building and
also this issue which happened
was a one by one situation between
two students with turkish origin
and in such a situation i think it is
not lawful
to give a a sanction
like this this school and also the
government
representatives until now they are not
replying
our appeal and our our letters
and it would be the next logical step
if they don't respond to our letters
that we will have to go to the court the
legal action
underlying this situation leaves
everything in a very messy place
stuck between a german school's
insistence on german being spoken
and respect for the languages of the
many different groups
that make up modern day germany peter
oliver rt
berlin
you